um
we were talking the other day about
um
hollywood
on this show
and we had mentioned the batgirl movie
that had gotten
shelved
meaning they're not releasing it
and there's a lot of people that
um were confused about that
um and they were thinking was that a
marketing ploy were they you know trying
to say like hey
uh they they thought maybe there'd be an
outpouring of like no we really want to
see batgirl
uh for whatever reason they're not
releasing it
um
and you know there's this idea that
everyone in hollywood's like is a
lunatic uh but they're that's only true
of certain people
and there are certain people that are
actually good
and they're actually people that are
trying to do the right thing and they
are good a good example
they're like an example for people and
one of them
uh and again this is a non-binary person
so i'm gonna try to do this
the right way and use all the right
things because i believe in you
but it's hard
and difficult to always remember so
don't
come for me if i say the wrong thing but
this is about an actor who is actually a
very
uh
this is someone you want to if you're a
child you want to kind of emulate this
guy
um who's not a guy who's see again
already already it's hard literally
already
it's this person this entity
um ezra miller
ezra miller is a non-binary
actor
who is
a great role model for children
and there you see them you see them
there nothing awkward about saying that
you see them there you see them there
good seems good english everyone you see
them there
with
uh a skull necklace and a fur coat
now
ezra miller
has been having problems
yes with the studio who is releasing the
movie the flash the studio is called
warner brothers
and there is a movie coming out called
the flash
it is a superhero movie of course it is
because um
we will refuse to make any movies
anymore unless they are about
superheroes or slaves those are the two
genres of film that we are interested in
making
uh
you're either being beaten and whipped
in a field or you're flying through the
air trying to save someone those are the
only two representations of any person
you will see
in cinema at the current moment
ezra miller was in this called the flesh
now what's going on with ezra miller
there's uh issues
there's problems right a long timeline
of uh legal troubles he's had a stay day
oh they
i'm sorry
just because he choked someone and
kidnapped someone does not mean
that you we can get all loosey-goosey
here with the terms
uh
ezra miller
early in the pandemic video leaked of
miller
choking a woman outside
the
i don't even want to pronounce it but in
reykjavik iceland it's a bar
in the clip which seems to pick up mid
confrontation
a smiling woman approaches miller and
appears to start a play fight
well
is this going to be one of those things
we have to side with them
miller takes her motion seriously and
says okay you you want to fight that's
what you want to do before grabbing the
woman by the neck pushing her against
the dumpster throwing her to the ground
at which point the video cuts out seems
excessive hey
ezra
at the time variety confirmed miller's
identity with the bar which said miller
frequent did the location when they were
in town so he choked a woman yes not
great not good not great pr for the
flash
in on january 27 2022
miller began their fateful year by
posting a video to social media
threatening a north carolina faction of
the klu klux klan this is a message for
the
blueville uh buelleville beulaville
chapter of the north carolina kkk the
actor says the clip um look if you all
want to die
i suggest killing yourselves with your
own guns okay otherwise keep doing
exactly what you're doing right now and
you know what i'm talking about then you
know we'll do it for you if that's what
you really want it's unclear what
prompted miller's threat to the hate
group
he has no known ties to the north
carolina city
see that's what makes me laugh is it's
not just a kkk in general it's a
specific
north carolina almost like he has a
problem
with a person in that specific faction
of the north carolina
uh chapter of the klu klux klan in
buelleville in beulaville like listen
guys uh we are going to figure out
what's going on
with the buellerville kkk um
march 28 2022
hawaii arrest number one miller spent
their spring in hawaii by all accounts
they were a menace
to everyone around them
on march 28th the actor was visiting a
local karaoke bar when they grew
agitated and began quote yelling
obscenities and at one point grabbed the
microphone from a 23 year old woman
singing karaoke
later miller london a 32 year old man
and failed to calm down after being
asked several times by the bar owner
miller's interactions with the two bar
patrons earned them
and by the way i can't get anything made
cause i sat next to alex jones on a
podcast
just to give you an idea
this person
is being this is all okay
who does he have photos of
they who do they have who do they when
did ezra miller come out as non-binary i
think a few years back okay right well
it's clearly helped their behavior
so
miller then post 500 bell
they let him out
yeah yeah um
miller argues the day in fact with a
victim of assault claiming a
self-identifying nazi in the bar
attacked him there's always nazis
everywhere popping up
a nazi in the bar attacked them
and explaining that they recorded
themselves being assaulted in order to
make nft crypto art
so ezra miller said i was attacked by a
nazi
and i recorded it to make crypto art
yeah basically yeah he's accusing he's
saying the knots he was doing they they
are saying they were saying they are
saying that
[Music]
when does he okay shortly after the
karaoke bar incident miller was arrested
again in hawaii for allegedly throwing a
chair that struck a woman in the head
at around one in the morning can i do
this if i become non-binary
can i throw chairs at women
and go crazy at bars in hawaii like
can i do all of that
is that because by the way i don't feel
really to be honest i didn't feel like a
man or a woman today i had uh
tomatoes and onions and and i rolled it
up and i didn't eat any bread and i
rolled it up with locks and cream cheese
and i ate it in the grocery store and i
just sat there while the crazy guy
talked about the rolling stones i didn't
feel my [ __ ] i if i had a vagina that
would have also been okay like i i felt
kind of like either one so what i'm
saying is if i fully embrace my kind of
gender neutral fluid identity can i
choke women outside of bars and throw
chairs at their head
it's a it's a fair question
um
this is one of those things with ezra
miller where everybody goes you got to
look into it you got to look into it you
got to look into it i've never looked
into it i just ignored ignored ignore it
because like
you know what i mean
so
then miller was accused of acting
inappropriately toward two different
children first the parents of iron eyes
an 18 year old environmental i mean
folks
the parents of tokata iron eyes
an
an 18 year old environmental activist
sought a protective order against the
actor saying who they began
and inapprop maybe you don't get your
pronouns um
honored if you throw chairs at women's
heads
could that be a good rule where we go
hey so for if you are going to be
violent we're not going to actually
honor the pronouns
so this is what they said
they said
ezra miller began an inappropriate
relationship with iron eyes when they
were 12 years old ezra uses violence
intimidation threats of violence fear
paranoid delusions and drugs to hold
sway over young adolescent takata
iron eyes parent said however posed from
an unverified instagram account believed
to be owned by iron eyes deny all claims
of abuse
so the parents claim one thing but iron
eyes says nope
we're doing fine soon after a 12 year
old and their mother were granted an
order of protection from miller after
describing an uncomfortable interaction
with the actor during a party in
greenfield massachusetts the mother and
then her 11 year old attended a party
held by their downstairs neighbor which
miller also attended at the event miller
began screaming in the mother's face
after accusing her of cultural
appropriation
and allegedly showed her a gun
saying quote talking like that could get
you into a really serious situation
after that miller reportedly now by the
way
you know i know gavin just got clipped
and everyone's gonna be you know and i
don't know what he did and gavin's
always been good to me but i
you know
here's the deal everyone's gonna be
talking about right-wing terrorism every
news article that you're gonna read for
the next 12 months will be about
right-wing terrorism which again
does exist
for sure
there are paramilitary groups that do
crazy things capital right whatever but
this type of behavior where he's like
showing a gun
to someone say talking about cultural
appropriation could we then move this
into the category of a guy who is maybe
influenced by the left a bit to doing
some things that are inappropriate
um because he's using all like the
terminology and he's got the gun and
he's still in the movie yet
i imagine if this was kind of on the
other side where he was talking about
the great replacement theory or any you
know and brandishing guns he might not
work that's all curious
i don't know
um so he points a gun at a mother's face
at a party
uh because she said something she i
don't know what she said after that
miller reportedly acted inappropriately
toward the child by hugging them and
touching their hips they automatically
were just weirdly drawn to me and kept
talking about how they love my outfit
they love my style
it was really uncomfortable i was
nervous i was scared to be around them
after he'd yelled at my mother and she
was crying why the mother then didn't
leave the party is odd to me
in august 2022 those closest now by the
way this person still has a job
they still after all the [ __ ] right the
me too the canceled culture
every this guy that's not a guy that's a
woman too that's non-binary that's lives
in the middle and it's just hard because
the name ezra
has always been a male name because it's
difficult it makes me
but
they
the choker
the choker and the brandisher of guns at
the mom
still has a job in hollywood odd
interesting
um
in august those closest to miller spoke
to insider for a report that paints the
actor is increasingly unstable really
and apparently running sort of a call
the report alleges that while miller was
in iceland in 2020 they walked around
town barefoot sporting long unclipped
toenails what may have been an infected
gash on their foot
miller rented an airbnb in the reykjavik
suburb of coppa vulgar and they ran a
commune with beds laid out on the floor
for artists expats and young women
they group led men they led group
meditations and claimed to possess
supernatural powers and also paid for
food lodging in marijuana but would
become violent if they perceived any
dissent within the group these days
miller runs another commune in vermont
which which has been described as having
rampant drug use and unsecured guns a
woman and a by the way
what is going on at warner brothers
how persuasive is this guy because you
know cold leaders can be charismatic how
charismatic
is this guy
that warner brothers is going yeah let's
just we'll figure it out and by this guy
i don't mean gendered guy i mean like i
mean like i call my friend michelle what
up guy
um
so miller's running a community vermont
again
um rolling stone ran a whole article
about that too like like the mainstream
media has picked it up guns bullets and
weed he was housing three young children
at this farm there were guns laying
everywhere the one-year-old had a bullet
in their mouth
they've been reporting on this for a
minute yeah so i i now go to the article
about warner brothers where everything's
kind of okay
because ezra miller came in and like
apologized like i'm like but my mind is
blown
by the fact
that this person
i mean how good of an actor are they
maybe they're great
it's kind of is where he met with them
miller who uses they them pronouns in
medsker met with new warner brothers
film chairs michael deluca and pamela
adley to discuss
not only how to stay on course for the
flash's june 23rd 2023 release date but
to reaffirm their commitment to the
movies wells apologize for bringing
negative attention to the production in
the company
over the past few years miller has been
at the center of arrested controversy
culminating with the actor posting me a
culprit on august 15 saying they were
seeking help from mental health issues
said the actor at the time i want to
apologize to everyone that i have
alarmed and upset with my past behavior
according to sources miller vowed to
seek help after learning that deluca and
abdi were considering all options for
flash including scrapping the 200
million movie
if things devolved further with miller
200 million
while the actress said to not have
minded the stream of bad headlines they
were spooked by the notion of the film
getting cancelled and jolted to take
action
they care about the flash it's one of
their favorite characters to play i mean
it's we're just living in a [ __ ]
disgusting
you know i mean it's like a joke it's
like a complete we're just living in a
complete joke you know
i mean it's you know i drive around this
town and you know today the tour you
know the tour buses and some of them are
like legit tour buses some of them are
just these little vans that are sawed
off and they have no you know no roof
and
one of the guys recognize me give me the
peace sign or whatever and you know i'm
like
you know like they're they're driving
around here and i'm like
you know get off these things like get
off these [ __ ] whatever you're
looking for here
whatever
stardom you're looking for is in
reykjavik iceland running a cult
like the it's such a joke the town has
become such a complete joke to people
it's a punchline of a joke
that i i'm amazed that that industry
still exists the tourism industry where
people are like show me the star i mean
it's just it's hilarious that's neither
here nor there um
i mean it's it's it's you know listen
yeah felony burglary on august 7th yeah
he broke into someone's house and stole
their liquor
and he got caught for that
in vermont
all right well listen i i the the heath
a thing annoys me so much we're not
going to talk about it anymore
um i is this part of coming out as
non-binary in hollywood the ability to
do all of these things is this part of
it
if it's part of it i think i would
actually like to do it and i would like
to get on board as soon as possible with
it i'm unaware of what makes violence
against women and children uh okay and
what makes uh running a cult okay but
apparently
you know i don't know it's strange it's
strange i have no interest in the flash
either way i don't care i don't care
about any of these i'm sick of these
superhero movies i'm sick of the
children uh that watch them and by
children i mean 35 year old losers
that are into [ __ ] superhero movies
you're disgusting
you're a disgusting person
and i only watch movies from the 90s ben
knows this if i have a movie night at my
house i only watch films from the 90s in
the early 2000s uh for the most part i
don't want to be involved in any of this
freak show that's going on right now
where people with peter pan syndrome and
i know that the studios are not making
money on other movies so they have to
make these to go global fine and some of
them are enjoyable you know whatever um
you know the big one with the hulk and
thor what was that one the avengers and
all that listen i i'm not saying that
they're you know listen they're fun
every now and then the fact that it is
the only genre of entertainment in
america is disgusting
the fact that it is the soul genre of
which you can partake in going to see a
film is disgusting
because this is a country that has a lot
of old people there's more old people
than young there's going to be so many
old people because of the birth deficit
or whatever that there's so many old
people
and all of the movies are uh superhero
movies
so
that's crazy to me
and uh
that just upsets me
but this story is just funny to me
because it is funny how many buttons
this person can push
how much criminality they can be
involved with
uh and
warner brothers just goes yeah whatever
it's cool it says full steam ahead in
the article full steam ahead good full
steam ahead well
you know
maybe ron desantis will put the military
in there i mean it's what'll you know i
don't know i'm just saying like
you know it's
it's like uh you know it's crazy if ron
desantis i will support him right now if
he promises to use the military to get
me work in this town like if ron
desantis will use the military to
literally go into these companies
with guns drawn and make me a star of
some of these
superhero films i will support ron
desantis and if he's if he's man enough
to make that promise where he will use
the military the power the full power of
the united states military to put boots
on the ground
in beverly hills
and hollywood
and get me jobs
then i will support him and i know that
i'm sure he's looking for an endorsement
from this show
that is the uh that is what is needed
that is the requirement for a desantis
endorsement is him using the military
to replace uh ezra miller with me
in the flash in the new flash film